Software unification
so that I no longer care what computing
device I pick up,
whether it's a laptop or a desktop,
whether it's one I own or one in a
public place,
uh,
whether it has a small screen or a large
screen.
Uh,
I sit down,
identify myself,
I tune in my information world.
Uh,
I get it in the same way on a no screen
computer in a car.
Um,
uniform access across all platforms,
computers,
telephones to my entire information
life.
It's easy to achieve in hardware.
They're hard software issues,
but they should have been solved 15
years ago.
So long from the other side of the fence
is,
um,
if I were to invest in a,
in a new company,
I would invest in some of the companies
that are working on so-called digital
furnaces.
Uh,
in five years,
everybody throws out all his cds and
dvds.
There are larger MP3 players,
a home stereo systems and t v V systems
are integrated and this is a billion
multibillion dollar transition.
As things stand,
it will be Sony and Google a Toshiba,
a few with very large companies doing it
and they won't,
they won't do it badly,
but they won't do it.
Well.
Uh,
I would invest in,
in one of the small companies that has
imaginative instead of recycled ideas as
to how to make that transition.
Um,
in two ways.
The service that print media
traditionally makes available,
um,
is editing,
which can turn
almost,
almost unintelligible random words into
intelligible language depending on how
good a writer you're dealing with.
Uh,
the vast majority of mankind today
writes badly and finds it difficult to,
may have good ideas,
but finds it difficult to write more
than an articulate sentence.
I'm really judging by my students,
um,
uh,
each year my students at,
yeah,
which is a good university.
We get very good.
Students are less and less able to
express themselves in writing.
So the print media,
um,
more than ever provides,
uh,
editing and provides,
um,
authority,
respectability.
If I go to a new stand 30 years ago and
there are five newspapers,
it's important for me to know that I
trust this newspaper.
And I don't trust that one.
But if today I go to the web and there
are 30,000 sites,
it's even more important for me to go to
a site,
which I have some reason to trust
consistently over the longterm.
I think the print media have failed to
make the most of their opportunity.
They know they may have all disappear
because they're approaching things in
the wrong way,
but,
but editing to produce coherent readable
text and authority so that readers know
how to spend,
no matter how much information there is.
I asked the same number of minutes in my
day and,
and I need to look to sources I trust
beginning with a print media,
newspapers,
I read magazines,
I read publishers I trust to give me
advice as to how to spend those minutes.
Print media will flourish if it does
that.
Don't know that it will.
The first part of your question,
um,
livestreaming is,
we defined it in first implemented it
back in the mid 1990s.
Um,
was a time based versus space are
surface based organization of
information.
The idea was that every electronic
assets you had,
every piece of information,
whether it was an email or an instant
message,
whether it was a,
a file or a spreadsheet,
whether it was a photo or an MP,
three would appear in a single time
ordered stream that mirrored the
evolution of your life.
So in principle,
the first thing on the stream would be
my birth certificate and the electronic
version of that.
My parents would put my records,
school records,
health records,
whatever,
when on a child onto the stream.
And the Stream is um,
uh,
continues to flow forward through time.
I can deal with the future is available
to me as well as the past.
So I can search in the past,
find what I want,
everything is fully indexed.
Um,
if,
if when I schedule things,
when I know things are coming up,
I put them in the future.
When I have something that I need to
return to that I don't have time for
now,
I put it in the future.
So,
uh,
and together without,
we had an interface,
um,
we thought it was important not to make
use only or the surface of the screen,
uh,
but to uh,
present displays in depth that made use
of the other virtual depth of the
screen.
So I wasn't looking at a surface,
I was more looking through a window into
an arbitrarily large information
landscape.
So instead of the mouse just moving a
cursor over the surface,
it would be a robot vehicle,
uh,
moving through three space or some
arbitrary space.
Um,
the basic idea was simple,
just a chronological timeline,
heterogeneous with absolutely everything
on it.
Um,
we have seen it a commercialized in two
different ways.
Um,
one way I,
the one that I'm allowed to talk about
it,
I no longer own these patents.
The patents have changed hands and the
patents are now subjective at enormous
lawsuit against Apple,
which is not mine because I don't know,
the patent I'm told is the largest
lawsuit in patent history.
Alcohol took these ideas.
I'm not in a position to say they stole
them.
I don't know if they did or not legally.
But these ideas are the basis of apples,
uh,
cover flow,
the way they display,
uh,
originally.
Um,
uh,
songs on itunes cover flow is now become
a standard way of displaying files on
virtually all apple platforms,
spotlight,
um,
which allows you to find files not by
name or folder,
but by content.
Um,
and time machine,
which is a,
a series of,
of archive things,
um,
without commenting on the legal aspects,
which I'm not capable of doing.
Those are like,
those are live streams and there are
other companies that have done similar
things.
Um,
that makes me angry personally,
not because of the money,
but because of the deliberate failure to
acknowledge work that we would have made
freely available as academics.
And that,
uh,
companies nowadays will not acknowledge
it because there's so much money
involved.
The same time on the network,
there are thousands of groups that are,
that are building livestreams or live
streaming for themselves in their own
way.
We love to see this activity.
There's a live stream,
that blog talking about all the
different life finger.
So,
so that's,
that's great.
And for that matter,
we're delighted to see apple do it too.
Um,
but when they're large companies that
work on it,
which is also the case with,
with friend feed,
um,
with the,
with the event stream,
um,
on facebook,
uh,
which is,
which is true of the aol aol Bebo
Stream,
which they actually call a live stream
or live streaming.
Um,
it's not,
uh,
it's not as if we want to stop that
activity,
shut it down,
but we'd like to see credit where credit
is due,
not just to me or even mean mainly to
me,
but to the graduate student actually
built the software,
worked tremendously hard,
published the papers,
put them in,
you know,
made them available and uh,
we'd like to see credit awarded.
There are certain subjects we'd seem to
me can be taught very effectively
online,
although they aren't.
I would love to see writing taught
online because of the university like
Yale,
much less than a high school where my
boys went to school,
a public high school in new haven in
Connecticut.
There are not enough teachers who are
able to teach writing well or in some
cases there are none.
Well there are always a few.
Teaching somebody to write is a isn't a
labor intensive activity.
I have to go through somebody's paper
and mark it up as a copy editor would do
sentence by sentence and I have to do
that repeatedly.
Now I could have a student take a hate
the paper and send it to somebody in
Alaska or India or anywhere who's
capable of doing it.
A worldwide network of writing,
teaching would be very effective.
It doesn't exist.
We don't have the right software tools.
We will at some point similarly for
marking exercises,
quantitative exercises,
uh,
maybe not so much in mathematics,
but certainly problem sets in physics
and chemistry and engineering and,
and things like that.
Uh,
where we're answers and methods are
clear cotton.
Um,
absolutely.
I would like to see that done online.
Um,
I think the universities as we know them
will be dead in 10 or 15 years.
I would like to see them replaced by
something better instead of something
worse.
And it's not clear which way it will go,
but the book is,
I'm abolishing the book is like
abolishing the symphony or Sonata form
or the sonic or,
or the wall painting.
Uh,
the,
the book is a form in which some of the
greatest masterpieces that mankind has
ever achieve.
Our are expressed.
Um,
uh,
not only fiction,
but uh,
they're great biographies.
Biographies is the greatest story.
And,
uh,
there are great science books that were
conceived as books,
Fiman Savers,
introductory lectures and physics,
which have a beginning and an end which
are written with style and penalize.
The book is,
is a unit and um,
it's such a brilliant Ergonomic unit.
Um,
and I take a book,
I can judge a book by its cover.
I can glance at it from the outside,
know what it is.
I can tell if it's a novel or a textbook
or a history book.
I can look at the side and tell about
how long it is.
I can flip through it and I don't need a
map to know that the,
where the table of contents are.
The index is,
I can find the photograph.
If they're a second no photographs,
I can write on it,
which is tremendously important.
If I read a book,
the,
the value to it,
to me and having the book another time
is to remember what I said,
what I wanted to know and so forth.
It's portable.
I don't have to worry about stepping on
it accidentally or I,
you know,
I can use it on the beach.
I can use it on anywhere.
Standing up in a boss.
I can.
It's,
uh,
it is the greatest design,
I think,
in the history of ergonomics.
I wrote a piece around it as long time
it,
we still have books because there are
so,
they're so brilliantly there.
They're there so brilliantly suited to
the way human beings absorbed
information and at their best.
They're among the most beautiful things
we have.
Um,
uh,
it's,
it's terrible to think of.
They're disappearing,
surviving only in,
in libraries,
but that's not going to happen.
People are too smart to allow it.
Even if the industry sometimes seems so
oblivious that it wouldn't care.